oh
I didn't see you had a baby there man
I'm sorry I ain't trying to fight nobody
with a baby
yeah hell yeah you won't
lucky [__] well you're lucky I'm
carrying this baby some of that
look man you need to move on all right I
already told you I'm not gonna fight you
that's what I thought Punk
won't go cause we can go right now dog
what's going on right man what the hell
are you doing man what what what what
trying to Bob and weave it what your
[__] ass punk ass [__] let's go
come on man come on no no don't look at
your boys look at me
ow
oh okay you think you hard all right but
you know what I'm gonna show you what
time it is right now okay slap me right
how about this huh now what you're gonna
do huh now it's gonna do you ready
because they can do it right now because
I can take you out man